Throughout my entire life,..
...I didn't see having a mentor as something that could play such a...
...crucial part in our lives until recent years.
When people are struggling in their personal life or their career,...
...it helps to be able to turn to someone whom you admire and trust.
Let me think about another way to explain this,...
...like someone who has already traveled down the road you're traveling,...
...and has done so successfully.
I previously thought that having a mentor means you're a failure...
...or makes you a lesser person.
But even a person like Bill Gates has a role model.
So I guess it makes you a smarter, better person.
I do have a role model,...
...but I can't personally contact them or get face-to-face advice.
Right now, I need a mentor who can give me realistic,...
...practical and encouraging advice.
But let's say that...
...for some reason my role model refuses or is unavailable to mentor me?
Hopefully it won't happen to you, but even if it does happen,...
...don't take it personally.
Not everyone wants or has the time to be a mentor.
Also, if someone asked me to be his or her mentor,...
...I would question whether or not I am successful enough to even be a mentor.
Anyways,...
...I think you can still learn from this individual by reading his or her books,...
...listening to his or her tapes and by watching his or her videos.
If you do that constantly,...
...you'll actually find yourself starting to think like this individual.